how to start a magazine with no money there's a [limited] belief that holds a lot [of] entrepreneurs back and
need to have x amount of dollars to start this business, or won't be successful [and]
what it does is until you get that money you don't do anything and
you just sit on your idea and
As a result you see other people making huge cash off of what you are supposed to be doing
Listen the money is not coming, and you don't need the money to be successful
[you] [look] at some of the most successful entrepreneurs in the world they started with nothing
[20] bucks they started their business
You don't need lots of resources, you just need to be resourceful
And you need to do something you need to get the idea out of your head
[I] actually start doing something because everybody has an idea
And you're always going to be that guy who looks at somebody else was successful and said see how he made millions
[that] should have been me the difference between him and you is he took action [I] got a question for one of my
One of my Facebook fans love you guys Facebook [France] Alvarez Joe Joe Alvarez
Anyway, wrote in to say he's trying to start a magazine as a student wants to start a magazine
Wants to know how can he get this started without money [doesn't] need to have money to launch this thing
This is a great question and you
Starting it from the right point of view how can I start this business this magazine without money?
the way to get started is
Don't think [about] all the costs that you have take about what you can do with what you have
Right don't think about the money you don't have think about what you can do with what you have
start online
Make a website
Whatever content you put in your magazine put it on the website
You don't know how to make a website start it on [Facebook]
Start creating content that gets people excited
I've had lots of offers from companies who wanted to turn my website into a magazine
I haven't had the right offer that I'm comfortable with and
Magazine has not been my top priority, but I could have turned it into one if I wanted to that was my goal
What happened and the website to get a website started is almost nothing, right?
A hosting cost a little bit domain name a little bit, but it's almost nothing to get this started
What you need to do is build a following?
Get people interested in this so that when you are able to go on launch [your] magazine
You're not going to blow your brains out on your cost and not have anybody actually buying it or buying ads in it
Build a following
Why do people want to partner with me to make a magazine because I have an audience. It's not just the content
it's the audience if I said here's the evan carmichael magazine people would go out and read it and buy it and
Advertise in it because I have a following
So whatever your magazine is about whether whatever your concept is start building a following start practicing start creating great content
You're going to get better
You're going to increase your skills your writing skills. You're publishing skills your editing skills your recruitment skills to bring people on board
You're going [to] do all this in a really low cost
Environment while you're building a following so that when you're ready to go launch a magazine
When you have people who are interested in this when you can take your following to them
You have an audience you have the skills you have the network
To make this thing successful and give you the highest chance of turning this into the magazine [of] your dreams, so think big
Here's our big picture. Here's what my magazine looks like that's the world. I want to create, but I'm going to start small
I'm going to start small and do something today. I'm going to post something on Facebook and then tomorrow
I'm going to do it again next day again mix it again
Then I'm going to get my own website build that up all working towards your big picture
Don't be the guy who just has this big picture and says until I get my 5K [50k] 500k
Get there
So I'm going [to] do nothing and then blame the rest of the world for not supporting you
This is on you to go out and make it happen
Believe for those are watching like the video give it a thumbs up below let me know what you think leave a comment underneath you
Have a question for me
I'll answer it if you leave a comment below subscribe to the channel if you like what you're [seeing]
And you want to see more. Thank you so much, and I'll see you soon